jo Leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen Video ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut
weiterfahren weiterfahren bitte wie man
unschwer erkennen kann befinde ich mich
hier gerade an einem Bahnhof genauer
gesagt Berlin Hauptbahnhof und von hier
fährt gleich mein Zug ab nach Kopenhagen
das ist ein Nachtzug und den habe ich
einfach vor ein paar Wochen mal gebucht
weil ich das immer mal machen wollte und
jetzt stehe ich halt hier ja ich habe
keine Ahnung wie das wird wir kommen da
in 12 Stunden an ich verbringe die ganze
Nacht da ich habe mir so ein Apartment
da gebucht und ich bin einfach mal mies
gespannt bis jetzt scheint es auf jeden
Fall so als wenn ihr noch nicht viele
Fahrgäste die Bock haben mit Nachtzug
nach Kopenhagen zu fahren das ist
natürlich auch nicht Deutsche Bahn
sondern der Tiger den Namen habe ich
schon wieder vergessen wir schauen uns
jetzt erstmal an was ich da genau
gebucht habe und dann geht's ab und Zug
bis gleich Leute was geht um ehrlich zu
sein ich bin schon wieder zu Hause von
meiner Reise aber ich wollte euch ja
noch zeigen was ich gebucht habe und
deswegen machen wir das mal eben ich
habe hier die Daten noch mal neu
eingegeben wir reisen mit dem snail
target das ist halt ein Anbieter für
Nachtzüge ganz europaweit sind die
glaube ich unterwegs aber halt immer mit
Ziel oder Start in Skandinavien irgendwo
genau und man unsere provad je nachdem
wann man Buch zwischen 500 und 1000
Schwedische Kronen was umgerechnet ihr
habt circa 50 bis 100 Euro oder so sind
hat dann aber auch nur einen Sitz und ja
erste Klasse habe ich bei mir im Zug den
ich jetzt halt für euch teste gar nicht
gefunden also es gab es da gar nicht ich
habe mir hier aber das private
Kompartment gebucht und habe am Ende ca
300 € für alles bezahlt also ich hatte
ein eigenes Apartment man kann hier
sehen Essen mit an Bord trinken mit an
Bord schlafen natürlich Fahrrad kann ich
nicht mitnehmen und ich dachte mir ich
Buch das einfach mal lass das auf mich
zukommen und wir schauen einfach mal wie
mir so meine erste nachtzugreise
gefallen hat und ob ich mit dem Angebot
für 300 € zufrieden war viel Spaß so
Leute das da ist auf jeden Fall der Zug
den ich nehme Stockholm zentral über
Malmö und so ein bumster ich hätte auch
ganz bis nach Stockholm fahren können
aber ich erzähle euch gleich beim Zug
glaube ich das nicht gemacht habe bin
halt schon lange genug unterwegs
[Musik]
ETF
220 ich habe mir einen ganzen Abteil
Leute was geht ich bin da also als Start
zum Nachtzüge testen vielleicht gar
nicht so verkehrt ich habe es so ein
bisschen anders vorgestellt also hier
könnten jetzt ja eins zwei drei vier
fünf Leute schlafen und ich habe ganz
viel Wasser das ist ja nett habe ich mir
dann hier einfallen lassen Schlafsachen
gibt's hier auch irgendwo vor kommen die
noch ich muss mich erstmal zurechtfinden
Leute und dann melde ich mich tschüss
Berlin Hauptbahnhof ja bis irgendwann
später hallo Leute ich fahre jetzt
Nachtzug 12 Stunden nach Kopenhagen ja
hallo einmal winken für die Kamera ihr
seht mich eh nie wieder ja ciao ciao
Digger ich bin jetzt einfach 12 Stunden
in diesem Zug in diesem Raum hier
danke schön also Leute ich habe jetzt
gerade erfahren das hier ist erstmal das
Ticket so sieht mein Ticket aus ich habe
hier den ganzen Apartment das ganze
Apartment gebucht Partner das ist
wirklich Apartment es hat mich auch 300
€ gekostet muss man sagen also schon
echt teuer ihr könnten auch noch mehr
drin schlafen aber ich habe jetzt
wenigstens meine Ruhe und was ich gerade
schon gehört habe total interessant um 2
Uhr morgens wird man hier geweckt weil
dann Crossen wir die dänische Grenze
also die border und dann kommt hier die
dänische Polizei rein und kontrolliert
einmal alle Ausweise schön durch perfekt
dicker ja da schlafe ich wahrscheinlich
eh noch nicht deswegen alles gut wir
sehen uns was geht ich melde mich mal
wieder ich bin jetzt mittlerweile eine
Stunde hier an Bord und konnte ein
bisschen was erkunden wir schauen uns
das ganze jetzt noch mal zusammen an und
ja dann schauen wir mal was es hier noch
so im Zug gibt und irgendwann dann
gleich lege ich mich auch schlafen ich
lasse es ganz mal auf mich zukommen und
wir schauen einfach mal wie mir so meine
erste nachtzugfahrt gefällt damit jetzt
nicht mehr jeder reingucken kann machen
wir das mal hier zu ich habe gerade
schon gezeigt wir haben hier 1 2 3 4 5
Betten hier oben war ich noch gar nicht
warte mal das ist aber auch was oh ja ja
ist halt noch Bettzeug Schlafsachen
anscheinend aber nicht die sind nicht
dabei ich muss auch sagen ich habe mir
irgendwie gedacht das ist ein bisschen
größer und man hat vielleicht auch ein
eigenes Badezimmer aber dem ist nicht so
ist auch nicht schlimm zum Glück habe
ich mir noch ein paar Snacks mitgenommen
weil eigentlich gibt es ja an Bord auch
ein Restaurant wo man sogar einen Tisch
reservieren kann und richtig schick
essen kann nur ausgerechnet das würde
jetzt eben gesagt in diesem Zug ist
heute kein Restaurant dabei sondern nur
eine Bar die heißt irgendwie die keine
Ahnung aber da schauen wir gleich mal
vorbei Wetten muss man halt auch selber
beziehen aber gut das ist halt so und
hier haben wir noch was ist das denn ach
so ja hier kann ich halt ausstellen wenn
ich nicht mehr hören will dass der
Kollege was sagt auch Verbot ist sowieso
Klimaanlage hier haben wir ganz viel
Wasser und hier ist halt noch
Ladestation für Handys da frage ich mich
auch was soll denn der oder die die hier
oben schläft machen Handyhülle also
braucht man ja ganz schön langes
Ladekabel ach so und wir können sogar
das ganze hier verriegeln okay da habe
ich aber den Schlüssel nicht zu okay
Licht aus Licht ah Nachtlicht ja hier
könnte man noch Koffer draufstellen das
war's eigentlich schon der Schaffner kam
eben und hat mich halt schon so kurz
begrüßt meinte jo ich habe dich hier
stehen also ich musste dem zwar mein
Ticket zeigen aber er wusste auch dass
ich der einzige hier in der Kabine bin
ja und ich befinde mich auf dem Weg von
Berlin nach Kopenhagen ich kann euch
jemand die Route zeigen die wir fahren
also wir fahren glaube ich über Hamburg
dann oben lang an Kiel vorbei und dann
ja über diese Zunge nach Malmö und von
da aus nach Kopenhagen also ein bisschen
crazy deswegen dauert das halt alles
auch so lange und ich habe auch
ursprünglich überlegt eigentlich bis
nach Stockholm zu fahren das wäre dann
16 Stunden gewesen also noch weiter hoch
weil ich die Chance nutzen wollte um
endlich mal wieder meinen favorite
Burger dort zu probieren und zwar bei
barrels das war mal übelst lecker aber
ich habe mich dagegen entschieden weil
ich wollte nicht 16 Stunden im Zug
hängen und ich muss ja auch irgendwie
wieder zurückkommen und ich bin die
Strecke von Kopenhagen nach Stockholm
auch schon mit dem Zug gefahren das ist
zwar ganz cool aber jetzt nicht so
besonders eher wenn man dann noch
nördlicher fährt wird es halt krass weil
diese sehen und Landschaften da sind
schon sehr sehr wild ich kann auf jeden
Fall jetzt einiges weg arbeiten hier
heute Nacht noch heute abend wir haben
Freitag Abend normalerweise bin ich nur
mit Freunden unterwegs heute sind wir
mal im Nachtzug warum auch nicht aber
Leute eine Sache die ich noch sagen muss
wir können ja eigentlich fünf Personen
drin schlafen Junge ist das dann voll
hier wie wo sollen die denn die ganzen
Sachen wenn du das geht doch gar nicht
und ich habe ja tatsächlich 300 €
bezahlt klar wir fahren nach Kopenhagen
in Dänemark ist eher das teuer aber das
finde ich schon eine Ansage muss ich
sagen schon teuer was halt auch schade
ist ihr könnt sie glaube ich sehen das
Dingen hat zwar WLAN aber ich habe nur
ein Balken Empfang jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt ob das geht ja da kann man
einmal die Deutsche Bahn loben weil ich
finde da ist das WLAN meistens jetzt in
Ordnung ist
floppt meiner Meinung nach No-Go weil
das kann man heutzutage schon erwarten
oder vor allem wenn man 300 Euro bezahlt
hat und dann ganze Nacht in unserem Zug
ist nämlich halt mein Hotspot so Leute
bevor ich mich schlafen lege wir haben
jetzt gerade 11:30 Uhr oder so werde ich
mal die Bar abchecken Restaurant hat ja
leider irgendwie da der Wagen wurde
vergessen oder so ist nicht mit dabei
voll schade fertig gefeiert so schön
dänisches Essen nices Bier dazu aber na
ja kannst jetzt machen ich lasse meine
Sachen einfach mal hier wird schon nicht
geklaut wo will der hin wir halten erst
in drei Stunden wieder so
[Musik]
muss auf jeden Fall den Wagen 217 da ist
die Bar the little Pub heißt das ja
check mal aus
[Musik]
also ich muss sagen ich habe mir das
irgendwie ganz anders vorgestellt alles
oh mann ey das wird so naja wir gehen
jetzt erstmal zurück vielleicht habe ich
auch einfach zu viele Filme geguckt das
kann auch sein also ja gut hier schlafen
auf jeden Fall hier Drink Snack
sandwiches and Candy dicker das war doch
keine Bar man man okay bin zurück Leute
also zack kann ich hier vielleicht auch
hinsetzen mit ein bisschen Glück boah ja
so Leute was geht ich bin jetzt hier
ganz oben auf jeden Fall habe ich mir
jetzt hier ein Bier gekauft dänisches
Bier nee doch nicht Löwenbräu
Entschuldigung sehr gar nicht Dänisch
und ein Käse Sandwich für 9 €
im the little Pub es kann wirklich sein
dass ich einfach zu viele Filme geguckt
habe und mir das alles falsch vorstelle
oder gut vielleicht ist es ja auch kein
besonders toller Nachtzug ich habe mir
ein paar Nachtzug Videos auch schon
vorher angeschaut wo wirklich coole
Sachen dabei waren aber das wird alles
so abenteuerlich angekündigt the little
Pub das hat dann auch so ein dänischen
Namen und dann ist das einfach nur so
eine kleine Kabine wo der gleiche Typ
drin sitzt der mich auch eben
kontrolliert hat und mir ein Käse
Sandwich anbieten kann mehr hatte der
gar nicht mehr na ja probieren wir mal
kurz ich habe aber auf jeden Bock auch
noch andere nachzüge zu testen also wenn
ihr krasse kennt schreibt es gerne mal
jetzt in die Kommentare das machen wir
dann noch aber jetzt erstmal Hunger
damals bei meinen Eltern haben wir immer
abends noch Brötchen gegessen vom Vortag
schmeckt sehr pappig aber da muss ich
jetzt durch eine Sache die mir aber noch
aufgefallen ist und zwar es gibt in
diesem Zug halt einfach kein krasses
Angebot auch wenn ich jetzt hier für so
gesehen 300 € bezahlt habe aber man
zahlt einfach für die Strecke irgendwie
ne ist auf jeden Fall kein Luxus
Nachtzug oder so naja ich mache jetzt
gleich bettfertig und dann gehe ich auch
schon schlafen schauen wir mal noch was
passiert was wird was wird achso ich
wollten noch hier die Toilette
sieht aus wie eine ICE
zack zack also eine Dusche hier an Bord
gibt es gar nicht und alles sehr
unspekt da QR würde ich mal sagen
[Musik]
so Leute Bett hinter mir ist fertig
gemacht dann kann ich mich jetzt
reinlegen wir haben jetzt gleich 12 Uhr
eine Sache die auch noch übelst dumm ist
es gibt nicht mal einen Steckdose hier
drin also es gibt nur diese USB Dinger
mein Laptop kann ich nicht mal laden das
heißt das ist ganz ganz Scheiße
leg mich gerne mal hier eben für euch
rein so
guck mal was denn wie soll ich denn hier
reinkommen
boah also für unbewegliche ist das
nichts also ich bin ja wirklich niemand
der viel meckert obwohl doch eigentlich
mecker ich schon viel ne immer in Videos
tut mir leid aber hier muss ich auch
meckern die Matratze ist ein Brett also
ich glaube der Schlüssel im Gefängnis
besser was ist fast wie Stein Boden
und neben mir schnarcht übrigens ich
lege mich jetzt auf jeden Fall gleich
schlafen und wir sehen uns dann morgen
früh in Schweden wieder weil ich lande
in Schweden und muss dann noch über
Nacht Kopenhagen was dann Dänemark ist
das ist aber nicht weit Leute gute
Nacht Scheiße gleich kommt ja noch die
Polizei und weck mich wieder verdammt
was sie mich auch gerade noch Frage hier
ist doch auch bestimmt schon mal jemand
rausgefallen bei ah nee okay ja gut ach
hier kann man noch so ein Ding
vorstellen ja gut ja aber nicht wirklich
nur naja okay jetzt haben wir hier
gerade Hamburg Hauptbahnhof erreicht
zack zack von hier aus noch so ein paar
beras die jetzt hier einsteigen der z.B
aber meine Kabine ist schon
abgeschlossen okay gut so Leute wir
haben jetzt fast 1 Uhr befinden uns
gerade ja kurz vor Kiel ich zeige es
euch mal hier sind wir fahren auf jeden
Fall jetzt noch hier oben rum und dann
glaube ich so und dann wie auch immer
nach Malmö ich habe keine Ahnung na ich
könnte jetzt mal in mein Bettchen Leute
gute Nacht
Leute was geht wir haben 2:15 Uhr sind
jetzt gerade angehalten kann jetzt sein
dass die Polizei kommt und neben mir
dieser ist sogar schleichen aus welchem
Jahrhundert stammt dieser Zug dachte der
liegt neben mir
dicker was ist denn alter
Junge
neben mir liegen wie solche denn bitte
schlafen Alter Leute wir sind gerade
mitten irgendwo angehalten hier ist die
Polizei im Zug sind auf jeden Fall einen
Ausfahrt planmäßigen Bahnhof gerade und
die haben angehalten und die Polizei hat
irgendwie rausgeholt lol und ich bin
jetzt wieder wach geworden vielen Dank
auch
[Musik]
morning
boah ich habe glaube ich am Anfang ganz
schön schlimm geschlafen jetzt ging es
noch so gerade aber mein Rücken tut weh
sind wir denn jetzt
schon da
lOL Ich komme aus einer halben Stunde an
so ja klar
so hinter mir haben wir noch so ein
Youtuber keine Ahnung was der macht aber
vielleicht hat er auch Entzug getestet
ich bin jetzt viel zu früh ey wir sind
jetzt hier in malmöbel boah wie sieht
das denn hier aus also ich bin ein
bisschen überfordert ich muss jetzt ja
auch noch den anderen Zug bin nach
Kopenhagen ich melde mich gleich noch
ich bin keine Ahnung überfragt so Leute
ich habe es geschafft ich bin im
Kopenhagen angekommen nach 12 Stunden
Fahrt oder so endlich wir haben jetzt
gerade kurz vor 9 Uhr war ja auch schon
mal das hier ist so ein Freizeitpark
oder so der ist hier genau in der Stadt
Wetter könnte besser sein aber naja ich
bin auf jeden Fall ziemlich fertig mein
Rücken tut auch extrem weh ich werde mir
jetzt gleich mein Hotel suchen und dann
machen wir noch mal ein Fazit und ich
muss auch erstmal duschen und so war auf
jeden Fall eine anstrengende Nacht aber
ich muss sagen Kopenhagen ist echte nice
city ah da ist ja direkt Hotel Leute bis
später
[Musik]
wie nennt man einen dänischen Moderator
der neben dem Straßenrand steht moderat
Herne
[Musik]
so Leute was geht bin mittlerweile hier
im Hotelzimmer konnte mich schon ein
bisschen ausruhen geht jetzt gleich aber
auch zurück das war ja meine erste
dachrückfahrt ich konnte das alles so
ein bisschen resümieren und wollte jetzt
noch mal ein kleines Fazit abgeben ich
muss sagen es war auf jeden Fall eine
Erfahrung und ich habe auch Lust dass
gern noch mit anderen Nachtzügen zu
machen also wenn ihr euch kennt schreibt
die super gerne in die Kommentare ich
habe es halt einfach ein bisschen dumm
gebucht also ich hätte nicht 300 €
ausgeben müssen wann bekommt auch wenn
man frühzeitig bucht diese Fahrt von
Berlin nach Kopenhagen für ungefähr 50
60 70 € und ich finde das geht da nicht
mein du kommst von Berlin nach
Kopenhagen musst du zwar mit fremden
Menschen sondern Abteilen aber an sich
ist das preislich dann okay die 300 €
die ich jetzt bezahlt habe für die
Leistung du kriegst da gar nichts du
hast absolut keinen Komfort diese Betten
sind hart wie Stein ich habe wirklich
Rückenschmerzen und ich kriege nie
Rückenschmerzen schlafen konnte ich auch
nicht wirklich alles hellhörig rechts
links neben mir alle am Schnarchen das
war wirklich ein Horror aber ich bin von
Berlin nach Kopenhagen gekommen schade
aber auch dass es diesen Restaurant
Wagen nicht gab so wie angekündigt und
nur dieses little Pub was einfach nur so
ein kleiner kantinenwagen war ich bin
fast am Glauben abgefallen als ich das
gesehen habe also das habe ich mir
wirklich ganz anders vorgestellt ich bin
mir sicher wir finden auch noch coolere
nachzüge also wenn man einfach irgendwie
umweltfreundlich von Berlin nach
Kopenhagen reisen möchte kann ich euch
den Nachtzug ans Herz legen sonst nicht
ja Leute vielen Dank fürs zuschauen wir
sehen uns hier schon ganz bald wieder
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen abonniert
super gerne den Kanal würde ich mich
echt freuen ich habe mir wirklich Mühe
gegeben bei dem Video und die nächsten
Videos die ich gemacht habe auf der
Reise werden auch cool also haut rein
Leute ciao